it's been about a month since i got my
galaxy buds live and when i popped them
in
and listened to them for the first time
i was blown away
they seemed to be the perfect blend
between the previous galaxy buds
and the air pods and i was certain that
they would cause me to ditch my earpods
pro
but after using them daily for a couple
of weeks before starting to switch back
and forth
i realized that i was wrong in this
review i'm going to cover all of the
positives and also all of the negative
things about these buds
and explain not only why i was wrong but
also why you should buy the galaxy buds
plus instead before we jump in if you
love what we do and you want to support
the channel go ahead and check out our
max tech shirts as well as the rest of
the merch
like our new premium zip up hoodie or
our masks down in the merch shelf below
the most unique thing about these buds
are definitely the bean
shape i was pretty surprised with the
design and happy that samsung chose to
go a new direction with these butts
instead of doing what
pretty much everybody else is they look
and feel amazing with a nice premium
glossy finish
and i love the gold color that they call
bronze i think
they sit flush in your ear making it
really easy to change your shirt or even
put on a helmet with them on
whereas with the ear pods it's very
difficult or even impossible
to do now unlike the buds plus these
don't have an
in-ear seal design which will be pretty
important and come into play
later in this review in terms of comfort
these are
very comfortable they fit perfectly in
my ear and they're super easy
to put in and take out they also stay in
very well and they don't fall out
even if i shake my head take a look
they're not going anywhere
they're definitely more comfortable than
the buds plus and that's partially due
to them not having that seal in design
the buds plus create pressure in your
ear because of that seal
which can make them a little
uncomfortable after a while
now the airpod pros also have that
seal-in design but they are extremely
comfortable because of a little valve
apple installed
which relieves that pressure the galaxy
buds live doesn't have that
issue now let's talk about the case the
buds live case has a new square design
so it's not as long as a previous buds
case
but it is a little wider and thicker the
case size is pretty convenient but i
think that the old case design
might be a little more comfortable in
your pocket especially for people that
have smaller pockets
getting into charging and battery life
the case itself uses wireless charging
or usb
type c to charge now without active
noise cancellation they have a total run
time of 28 hours which is great
and for comparison the butts plus was
rated at 22.
now the actual buds themselves are rated
between six to eight hours depending on
the setting
instead of an advertised 11 hours for
the buds plus
when i first got these that seemed to be
quite a big drop in battery life
but that's actually because the buds
plus default to their normal mode which
is fairly quiet
i like to use those in the dynamic mode
which drops the battery life to about
eight to nine hours because they get
louder and they sound a lot better there
with these lives they actually sound
perfect and fantastic
in the normal mode so the real world
battery life was about
5 to 6 hours throughout all the time
that i used them i never felt limited by
the battery life
and on top of that they charge really
quickly just 5 minutes will give you
over half hour of listening now getting
more into sound quality the lives
blew me away they are very loud which i
love
because it really helps with the
unsealed design
and if you're listening to quieter
podcasts or videos it's great to have
the extra room to boost the volume
the bass is deeper and richer sounding
than the previous buds
likely because of the large 12
millimeter drivers
the highs are very crisp and they sound
great
now sound quality is obviously
subjective but to me
these are the best sounding earbuds that
i've ever tried
even beating out the airpod pros and
those really nice sony wf-100 or 1000
xm3s that's way too long of a name now
for some people the base and the highs
might be
a little bit too much but you can of
course tune that using the settings
in the app not only that but they work
very well with my
iphone they pair quickly and
consistently every single time
and they're actually a little bit louder
using the iphone
than using my note 20. onto microphone
quality
in samsung's keynote they said that they
have greatly improved the microphone
quality since the buds plus and i could
say that that is definitely
true my wife had no issue hearing me
when she actually did complain about the
previous buds
but the airpods are still ahead take a
listen for yourself
this is the microphone quality with the
galaxy buds live
and this is the microphone quality with
apple's airpods pro
the difference is noticeable but it
isn't huge so
for most people the buzz life will do a
good enough
job and that won't be a complaint now
let's get into the drawback of these
buds
that made me change my mind about them
as i mentioned earlier the buds alive
have an open ear design
unlike the previous buds plus which have
that seal in
because of that there is a shocking
amount of sound
leakage quite a bit more than even the
original earpods due to all the
vents and it doesn't help that they get
so loud
with that if you don't want people to
hear your music
you have to turn them down so much so
that the outside noises
start creeping in and are very apparent
pretty much
like open back headphones if you've ever
used those
now if you don't like sharing your music
with everybody else
i would say these are not for you it's
very interesting that these buds live
are the first open earbuds in samsung's
line
because they're also the first to
include active noise cancellation
now that doesn't make much sense because
you can't seal out
noise so how would the active noise
cancellation even work well
that was my biggest concern when i first
read the specs with these
and that's the thing after using these i
could definitely say
that it doesn't work well at all it only
removes some lower frequency
sounds leaving all the mid and high
frequency noises
when i was using these buds they did a
pretty good job of getting rid of the
low frequency sound from the always-on
furnace next door to us but at the same
time i started to notice the higher
pitch sounds
from the air flowing through the vents
above and that was
even more annoying so i turned the
active noise cancellation off
i was still optimistic though and
thought that they would work better for
other environments
but as soon as i took them home and
tried using them while mowing the lawn i
was
disappointed the active noise
cancellation didn't do
anything there was absolutely zero
difference
and i struggled to hear the podcast
while mowing my lawn
and the whole time i was really wishing
that i had taken my buds plus
or even the airpods pro with me i then
tested while vacuuming and the active
noise cancellation
barely changed the sound so going
forward i found myself having to switch
between using my buds live
for listening to music and my earpod
pros
anytime i needed noise cancellation now
obviously
that is not convenient and on top of
that most people can't
and won't buy two sets that's the thing
a good set of wireless earbuds need to
meet
a wide range of needs and even though
the buds
live have really great sound quality
they have good battery life and they
have improved microphones and they look
great the fact that the advertised
active noise cancellation is so terrible
really makes it a deal breaker for me
the butts plus didn't have
active noise cancellation but the seal
design meant that they were passive
and that worked really well so with that
i really wish that samsung made the
lives a sealed design as well
but retaining this shape the active
noise cancellation would work great and
the sound quality in mics would still be
just as good
with that sound leakage would be greatly
reduced and they would be a fantastic
unique set of buds that would work for
almost
anyone at this point the galaxy buds
plus don't look as good and they're not
flush
but they are a lot more versatile and
they can be bought for a fair bit less
money
yes the mics don't sound as good but
they are usable
and as far as audio quality they still
sound really good
no they don't sound as good they're not
shockingly great
but most people that haven't tried the
lives will be very happy with the sound
quality
so unless you need the flush fit or you
want that open design that leaks sound
and lets in noise
i think that most people will be better
off buying the older galaxy buds plus
of course you can spend more money and
get the airpod pros which are more
comfortable than either one of these and
they have better mics than other of both
of these
and they have better noise blockage and
cancellation with the active system
but they do sound worse and they do cost
a lot of
money whatever you guys decide to do
i'll leave links down below where you
guys can score
some great deals especially on the
galaxy buds plus
let me know which one you end up
deciding to go with if you enjoyed this
video tap that like button and click
that circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one
and make sure to check out one of those
two videos over there especially the
comparison
between these two thank you guys for
watching and i'll see you in the next
[Music]
one